Voilà
C'est mon nouveau chez moi ! Ça vous plaît ?
J'adore changer.
Il est temps pour moi de revenir sur cette année 2016,
ce que ça représente pour moi,
vous allez peut être découvrir des choses
C'est parti !
L'année commence très fort avec l'aboutissement de plusieurs mois de boulot,
c'est la diffusion de mon court-métrage "La Cartouche",
au Grand Rex à Paris
Voilà Cette avant première était très importante pour moi,
parce que je voulais avoir la réaction du public en direct,
et l'ambiance était vraiment super
et puis les bénéfices ont été reversé à l'association "C'est que Du bonheur",
une association que j'affectionne tout particulièrement.
J'étais super content de publier enfin mon court métrage "La Cartouche"
C'est le projet qui m'a fait le plus kiffer...
7 jours de tournage, un casting au top, une équipe au top, un générique par Big Flo & Oli,
une tortue en 3D, et une séquence tournée avec Shigeru Miyamoto, le créateur de Mario.
Il a bien voulu tourner une petite séquence avec moi, donc ça c'était vraiment incroyable
Merci Myamoto-San, merci Nintendo.
On m'a plagié !
Voilà, j'ai découvert ça cette année...
Un russe et un italien ont repris mes vidéos, mots pour mots dans le plus grand des calmes
Cinq pourcents
musique de westerne
le même dialogue en italien
Aaah, c'est la rançon de la gloire, j'leur en veux pas...
je vais juste les poursuivre en justice !
J'ai été jury du "Nikon Film Festival", c'est un concours de court-métrages,
présidé cette année par l'acteur Jacques Gamblin.
Je fut très honoré, c'était vraiment l'éclate de visionner des centaines de court-métrages,
et c'est là qu'on se rend compte de la force de création des français,
et de tout ce qu'ils peuvent inventer, donc bravo à tous les participants,
bravo à tous ceux qui racontent des histoires tous les jours,
continuez comme ça et ne vous arrêtez pas.
On peux dire que c'est l'année de la transformation physique, j'adore changer de gueule,
alors j'ai pas hésité, j'ai fais le patron de Youtube avec un faux crâne et une perruque et une moustache,
j'ai fait l'inventeur des animaux avec une coupe en brosse et un très beau bouc,
je vous épargne mes cheveux dans "La Cartouche", dans "Les Pubs VS La Vie 2",
dans "Être Youtuber"
Bref 2016, c'était l'année de la perruque.
Et cette année je vais euuuuh... Continuer !
Devinez qui est la personnalité préférée des français?
C'est Omar Sy
Moi j'ai été élu la personnalité préférée des 7-14 ans par le journal d'investigations le "Journal de Mickey".
Donc merci beaucoup, ça me fait très plaisir,
je suis un peu comme votre grand-frère pour vous les jeunes, voire votre père, c'est possible
Mais c'est pas grave, merci beaucoup
Et j'ai un feeling, l'année prochaine ça va être Squeezie, j'le sens !
2016 pour moi, c'est aussi l'année des rencontres exceptionnelles.
Par hasard, pendant mon séjour au Japon, je tombe sur le premier Youtuber du monde
51 millions d'abonnés : PewDiePie, voilà,
qui a été très très sympa, on a fait une photo.
J'ai participé à un tournage un petit peu fou puisque j'ai tourné avec James McAvoy,
"professeur Xavier" dans "X-Men", j'ai adoré son rôle dans "Wanted".
C'est un tournage un petit peu bizarre puisque lui il faisait ses répliques pendant que nous,
avec Julien Josselin, on lui faisait des grimaces.
je suis pas sûr que ce soit une bonne expérience pour lui, mais en tout cas nous on a kiffé, ça c'est sûr !
Est-ce que c'est la seule rencontre cette année-là ? Pas du tout !
La Fox m'a contacté pour organiser une rencontre avec un de mes réalisateurs préférés : Tim Burton.
J'ai vu tellement de fois tous ces films, j'en faisais même des dessins,
j'y croyais pas et finalement ça s'est fait,
j'ai pu discuter avec Tim Burton et c'était super enrichissant.
On a parlé de créations, de mise en scène, de dessins, de son film "Miss Peregrine et les Enfants Particuliers",
et c'était vraiment une super expérience donc merci beaucoup Tim, merci la Fox, top !
Vous le savez maintenant, c'est plus un secret, j'adore le manga Dragon Ball, j'en parle dans mes vidéos,
et je me suis dis que ce serait cool de faire une vidéo avec des passionnés du manga,
et j'ai fait un quiz Dragon Ball, voilà, sur ma chaîne "Cyprien Gaming",
ça s'est super bien passé, c'était une top ambiance
et je fut très honoré d'avoir la voix officielle de Sangoku enfant !
Jhon Rachid : Oh là là Brigitte !
Cyprien : C'est énorme hein ?
LucassTV (présentateur) : C'est magnifique, hein ?
Merci beaucoup Brigitte, merci beaucoup à tous les participants, c'était vraiment l'éclate.
Comme les deux années précédentes, je suis allé à Londres pour le tournage du "YouTube Rewind",
cette année, j'y suis allé avec Squeezie,
et autant les années précédentes mes passages sont comptés en secondes,
autant là ça se compte en DIXIÈMES de seconde.
Vous en voulez plus ? C'est parti !
Voilà ! C'est tout !
Vous... Ah non ! Vous me verrez pas plus ! J'espère que ça vous a plu, hein !
La légende raconte que l'année prochaine, on nous verra... UN centième de seconde.
Donc ne clignez plus des yeux !
Merci pour tous vos dessins, après ma vidéo sur ma passion du dessin,
j'ai adoré partagé ma passion avec vous, parce que c'est un truc que je fais depuis que je suis gamin
je sais qu'il y en a plein d'entre vous qui ne dessinent pas et qui s'en foutent,
mais pour moi c'était cool de vous en parler.
L'année 2016, c'était aussi une année riche en collaborations,
vous m'avez vu sur mes deux chaînes YouTube, forcément,
mais aussi sur la chaîne YouTube "Dans ton Corps", chez "Golden Moustache", chez "Tsuko G.",
dans le documentaire "Nos Petites Histoires", dans le studio 404, sur la chaîne du CNC,
chez Thomas Gauthier, dans "Thug Life", dans "La Nouvelle Édition", dans "les Kassos"
-Je suis passif agressif
-Hein hein, et ouais
-ET ÇA C'EST DU PASSIF ?!
-AW !
Cette année, j'ai bossé pendant un moment sur un projet très secret,
et j'étais très très content de pouvoir enfin vous en parler, vous le montrer, et le lancer.
J'ai créé un jeu mobile !
Le mec il fait une BD, des court-métrages, et un maintenant il fait un jeu ?
Bah oui.
Je vous présente le Nope Quiz qui est disponible sur Android et iOS gratuitement.
C'est un jeu où vous allez beaucoup rager, il faut répondre à des questions,
mais y a des pièges absolument partout.
C'était beaucoup de travail : du développement à l'écriture
en passant par les musiques, les graphismes, l'animation
Donc merci à toute l'équipe qui a bossée là dessus.
C'est vraiment un rêve pour moi de créer un jeu et y a une personne qui était très importante dans ce projet,
pour vous expliquer ça, je vais revenir 15 ans en arrière : j'avais 12/13 ans, dans le Var,
et je passais tout mon temps libre à créer des trucs avec mon pote Jérémy, qui est ici sur cette photo
du 18 mai 2002, c'était pour mon anniversaire ; je suis là, et lui il est là.
Je vous le montre pas trop près, il a honte de sa gueule sur la photo.
On passait tout notre temps libre à créer des trucs. On a créé des petits jeux vidéos,
où moi je m'occupais des dessins, essentiellement.
On a grandit ensemble, on est montés sur Paris, lui il s'est spécialisé dans le développement sur mobile,
moi je fais des vidéos, mais ça vous êtes au courant.
Et on s'est dit : et si on faisait ce qu'on faisait il y a 15 ans ?
C'est-à-dire créer des jeux mais toute la journée cette fois-ci, et c'est ce qu'on a fait
Jérémy a quitté son taf et maintenant on créer des petits jeux ensemble.
Et même si le Nope Quiz c'est un petit jeu, c'est la continuité de ce qu'on faisait quand on était gamin,
avec les mêmes personnes, la même passion, et on va avoir encore pleins d'autres projets :
on va mettre à jour le quiz, il va y avoir plein d'autre contenu dans pas très longtemps,
et on va aussi faire d'autres jeux, des jeux plus long, qui seront payants aussi,
voilà, désolé... 'faut bien que Jérémy mange...
Merci à tous ceux qui ont déjà téléchargé le jeu,
ça a été en top d'App Store et de Google Play pendant très longtemps, pendant les périodes des fêtes,
donc ça me fait très plaisir, restez pas loin pour la suite.
Et vous le savez très probablement mais ma chaîne YouTube a dépassée les 10 millions d'abonnés,
Je vous remercie chaleureusement. Je ne m'étale pas. Pourquoi je ne m'étale pas ?
Parce qu'une vidéo spéciale que j'ai tournée pendant le mois de décembre va arriver dans pas très longtemps,
c'est ma prochaine vidéo. En indice sur la vidéo, je peux vous dire que je n'étais pas chez moi,
que j'ai vécu ça pendant plus de 10 jours, et peut-être il y a un trophée en diamant à la clé,
c'est possible, je n'en dis pas plus, ça arrive très bientôt.
J'ai oublié pleins de choses pour cette année 2016 : ma tournée de dédicace pour ma BD, la Paris Games Week,
Los Angeles, tout ça... mais en tout cas merci pour cette année de folie, c'est un truc de fou
Et pour 2017, j'ai pleins de projets : jeux, BD, court-métrages, série...
Vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu parler...
Donc restez dans le coin, bonne année et faites comme moi : J'reste ghetto.